[موسيقى]
اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى اخبار الساعه نبداها
بابرز العناوين
سيكوندمات والاخيره تفرض على النظام
عقوبات التطال مسؤولين وكيانا
ابو عجيل الى مسعود وتبدا محاكمته
والبرلمان الليبي يعتبرها جريمه
وزير الدفاع الفرنسيه او وزير الدفاع
الفرنسيه سابقات تكشف للعربيه تعرضنا
المحكمه الخاصه باغتيال الحريري لضغوط
كبيره لتبديل قرارها النهائي
بوتين في ماء خسائر جيشه في اوكرانيا
تفقده دعم الخلفاء واشنطن تضعوا شروط
جديده لمده كيف بالسلاح
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى اخبار الساعه بتنفيذه اول
لاعدام لاحد المحتاجين قبل اقل من اسبوع
وجه النظام رساله ترهيب لشارع المنتظر منذ
ثلاثه اشهر نتحدث عن ايران لكنه بتنفيذ
الاعدام الثانيه اليوم لمحتج اخر وجه
النظام الايراني رساله استفزاز الي اوروبا
التي ادرج عقوبات ضد النظام اليوم ايضا
ايران نفذ الاعدام واوروبا فرضت العقوبات
بينما بقي زخم الاحتجاجات في كل المدن
الايرانيه بل وتصاعد اكثر بعد الاعدام
الثاني
ماما شادي
ورقه الاعدام لتخويف المحتجين ضاربه
الحائط بكل التحذيرات والتمديدات الدوليه
عمليه الاعدام الثانيه
مشهد وتهمه قتل عنصرين من القوه الامنيه
طعنا بالسكين
واجرحي اربعه اشخاصا اخرين مجيد رضا رحنا
ورد
في مدينه مشهد في تنفيذ سريع للحكم بعد
اقل من شهر
رغبه همم السلطه الايرانيه في ترهيب
المحتجين
[موسيقى]
وعلى قبر مجيد رضا رحنا ورده هتفت وهي
تبكي قاتل وحكمه باطل انها والده الشاب
الايرانيه الذي اعدمته ايران اليوم
الاهلي
[موسيقى]
الغربيه
يبدو بان نزيف حاله الاعدام سيظل مستمرا
وابقى المنظمه الايرانيه لحقوق الانسان
فقد وصل عدد المحكوم عليهم بالاعدام من
بين المواطنين الذين اعتقلوا خلال
الاحتجاجات التي تعم البلاد الى 11 شخصا
على الاقل والى ذلك زادت حده التمديدات او
الانتقادات الموجهه الى طهران بعد حاله
الاعدام الثانيه سيما من اوروبا حيث ادانت
المانيا بشده حالتي الاعدام التي نفذتها
حتى الان
من الواضح تماما ان هذه الاعدامات العلنيه
هي محاوله سافره للترهيب الناس ضد النزول
الى الشارع وهي محاوله لتخويف المتظاهرين
فقط لانهم خرجوا الى الشارع وعبر عن
ارائهم وارادوا العيش بحريه مثلنا هناك
المزيد من عمليات الاعدام والمزيد من
محاولات التخويف ولهذا نحن في اوروبا
والمانيا نتابع الوضع في ايران ليل نهار
ونؤكد اننا نقف الى جانب الابرياء في
ايران
وفي مزيد من ردود الفعل الغربيه اكد مسؤول
الشؤون الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبيه
جوزه بورريل عزما دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
اتخذا اي اجراء بمقدوره دعم الشابات
والمتظاهرين السلميين كما علق وزير
الخارجيه النمسا على حكم الاعدام بايدينا
بادانه ايران على استمرارها في التصعيد
بدل التحليه
[تصفيق]
حالتها الاعدام الاخيرتين اثارتها حفيظه
العديد من الدول الاوروبيه ما حدث بها فرض
عقوبه جديده على النظام الايراني شملت
الحزن الجديده اضافه 20 مسؤولا وكيانا
ايرانيه الى قوائم العقوبات كما تم ادراج
التلفزيون الايراني الى لائحه العقوبات ضد
طهران فضلا عن العقوبات المرتبطه
بالاحتجاجات فرض الاتحاد الاوروبي عقوبات
بسبب بتوريد الاهرام مسيرات لروسيا وشمال
اربعه مسؤولين واربعه كيانات ايرانيه
الينا من اصله عضو منظمه حقوق الانسان
الاحوازيه عمار تسائي اهلا بك سيد عمار
يعني هل بمقدور الاتحاد الاوروبي ااا
اليوم فرضه مزيد من هذه العقوبات الى اي
درجه من الممكن ان تثني النظام الايراني
عن استخدام هذا العقاب ضد المحتاجين
السلميين
لك وللمشاهدين الكرام نعم الاتحاد
الاوروبي هو الان بادر بحسنه من العقوبات
واعتقد ان هناك همم حزمه اخرى او حتى ربما
حزم اخرى قادمه
لمنع ايران من انتهاكات حقوق الانسان لانه
الان في اوروبا همم الصحافه الاوروبيه
والناشطينها الحقوقيين في مجال حقوق
الانسان يغطون على هذه الدول بشكل
كبير وبشكل قوي لحمايه الهمم الشعوب في
ايران وحمايه ال- همم المتظاهرين وفي
الحقيقه السياسيين في اوروبا هم يحاولون
قدرهما يستطيعون
قدره ما يستطيعون ان يرضون الشارع
الاوروبي ولذلك هذه الحزمه من من العقوبات
لا اعتقد انها الاولى بل بدايه مجموعه من
الحزم لمعاقبه ايران خاصه وان النظام
الايراني لم يكترث لها ويبدو انه سائر في
مزيد من الاعدام
المتظاهرين السلميين في ايران من قبل
الاتحاد الاوروبي ما هي الخطوات
هناك خطوات كثيره يعني هناك مثلا في
المجال السياسي ربما مثلا الاوروبيين
يستطيعون سحب الدبلوماسيهم او طرد الهي
ئات في السفارات
الايرانيه التي لديهم وهذا
يشكل ضغط سياسي كبير كما ان العقوبات التي
تاتي باسباب حقوقيه لها تاثير اكثر ولها
يعني لها اثر اثر كبير لانها تختلف منها
العقوبات التي تخص الملف النووي لان
العقوبات التي تاتي لاسباب حقوقيه ربما
تترتب على الاشخاص الذين
تفرض عليهم
معاقبه قانونيه من المحكمه الدوليه او من
المحاكم الدوليه
ولذلك اوروبا وامريكا لديها الكثير من
الاوراق اذا ارادت
تستخدمها لحمايه المتظاهرين السلميين
والمحتاجين في ايران يمكنها استخدام ذلك
ومثلا ايضا تصنيف الحرس الثوري الذي هو
يعد الماكنه الاقتصاديه والم الماكينه
الصناعيه والقمعيه ال- النظام تصنيفه همم
يمكن ان يضع القاده في هذه القوه وفي
القوه الحرس الثوري في مازق كبير هذه كلها
اوراق يعني الاتحاد الاوروبي
والدول الاوروبيه
لم تستقدم ولم تكن جاده في معاقبه نظام
ايران الانتهاكاته لحقوق الانسان
منظمه حقوق الانسان الاحوازيه عمار تساهيه
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
في انفجار استهدف فندقا بافغانستان ومشاهد
توثقوا قرار النزلاء الفندق
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله اثار تسليم المواطن الليبيه
ابو عجينه
الحكومه عبد الحميد طبيبه في دائره
الاتهامات بل والخيانه العظمى كما وصفها
البرلمان الليبي البرلمان يعتبر ان تسليم
ابو عجيل مسعود لواشنطن جريمه ضد القانون
الولايات المتحده باستغلال ظروف البلاد
باعاده فتح ملف القضيه
وفي اطار التوعد والتحذير طالب مجلس
النواب الليبي بمحافظه الكل من تورط من
الليبيين في اعاده فتح ملف اللوكر بيبي
تهمه الخيانه العظمى وهكذا المجلس انه
سيلاحق عبر النائب العام كل المتورطين في
القبض على مسعود ابو عجيله او ابو عجيله
مسعود كما اشار مجلس النواب الليبي في ذات
الصدد الى انه حضر حكومه من الاقدام على
تسليما
من واشنطن مراسل العربيه حسين الطود حسين
اهلا بك ما هي ظروف هذه المحاكمه على ماذا
استند على الادعاء في فتح ملف في هذه
القضيه من جديد
تحيه لك عادل انا الان اقف امام المحكمه
التي من المفترض ان يظهر فيها بعقيله كان
من المفروض ان يظهر قبل ساعتين على الساعه
1:00 بتوقيت واشنطن دي سي ولكن تم تاخير
ذلك ساعتين من المفترض حسب معالمنا ان
يكون الان اما سيدخل او انه في الداخل حيث
سيتم همم توجيه التهم له من قبل القاضي
كما انه سيؤكد للقاضي ان كان هو ابو عجيله
ام لا همم على ماذا ارتكز الامريكيون اعلن
انهم سيواصلون همم
محاولاتهم لتحقيق العداله لاسر ضحايا
لقربيا رغما انه تم اا- اا اقفال الموضوع
وكمان ذكرنا سابقا لان الرئيس الامريكي
همم الاسبق جورج دبليو بوش عام 2008 اصدر
مرسوما يؤكد فيها التزام الولايات المتحده
بانهاء همم التام لاي مطالبات مستقبليه
واقفال اي قضايا فتحتها عائلات ولكن ما
جرى الان ان الموضوع همم القضيه تم اعيده
عام 2016 عندما علم القضاء الامريكي بان
المخابرات الليبيه حققت مع ابو عجيله وان
ربما يكون متورط بقضيه لوكربي وعام 2020
المدعي العام الامريكي وجهتهم بعجله همم
الاجواء العامه هنا خاصه بالنسبه
لاهالي ضحايا لوكربي هم عبروا عن ارتياحهم
بان ياتي احد المتورطيه المجتمع بيتورطهم
في قضيه لوكربيلي يحاكم يواجه العداله
الامريكيه كما قال هنا في الولايات
المتحده بدل اسكتلندا همم بعضهم اعلن انه
سياتي الى واشنطن دي سير العاصمه ليتابع
المحاكمه من
المحتمل ان يتم الان عن الجلسات المحاكمه
الخادمه كل هذه الامور طبعا همم طلقه
ترحيبا من قبل عائلات واثر ضحايا طائره
تحديدا شكرا جزيلا لمراسل العربيه من
واشنطن امام المحكمه
ورغم ما يحيط به حيثيه تسليم ابو عجيله
للولايات المتحده من غموض كان لافتا
تصريحات شقيقه احد ضحايا تفجير لوكربي في
مقابله مع قناه فوكس في النيران لها يدن
في القضيه
اهلا بك دكتور
بدايه التحيه لحضرتك ولكل مشاهدي قناه
العربيه المحترمين طبعا الدستور الليبي
شانه شان باقي الدساتير الاخرى ينصه على
مبدا عام وهو مساله حفاظ وعلى كرامه
المواطن الليبي في الداخل وفي الخارج وبان
قضايا مثل هذه القضايا التي تتعلق باحاله
اي مواطن ليبي للمحاكمه في الخارج لابد ان
تستلم الى اتفاقيات ما بين يعني الدوله
الليبيه والدوله ال ال المتعه او الدوله
المتعاقده
ومدى همم اظهار قدره وكفاءه القضاء الليبي
على المذي قدما بمثل هذه المحاكمه
بالاضافه الى ذلك ان هذه الاتفاقيات الذي
تمت بين الدوله الليبيه في فتره النظام
السابق مع الولايات المتحده في فتره يعني
الرئيس همم جورج همم
تمت بموجب اتفاقيات وهذه الاتفاقيات
اما التاكيد عليها بموجب قرارات سياديه في
الدولتين لتدخل هذه الاتفاقيات ضمن
المنظومه التشريعيه في الدولتين وبالاضافه
الى ذلك صدرت احكام قضائيه في فتره
المحاكمه لا من قبل القضاء الاسكتلندي
لانهاء هذه القضيه استنادا الى الاتفاقيه
التي تمت ما بين الدولتين ما يحصل الان هي
مساله ليست لها علاقه بمساله يعني اقامه
العداله او انصاف الضحايا ما يحصل الان
الان هو مصلحه ضيقه للطرفين اولا له عبد
الحميد الدبيبه الذي يعني همم يحاول يعني
عبثا
يكسب الموقف الامريكي ونحن ندرك تماما بان
الامريكان في نهايه الامر يعني استغلوا
ظرفه الان وبطريقه غير اخلاقيه في محاوله
من قبل البقاء بالسلطه ولا يكسب الموقف
الامريكي وهو يعتقد واهم في هذه المساله
وايضا موقف ال ال يعني الاداره الامريكيه
الحاليه في ابتزاز هذه القضاء هذه القضيه
انا في تقدير الان ابو عجيله مسعود كامر
واقع الان وصل في لدى القذافي المتحده
الامريكيه ومن ثم يجب على الليبيين الان
الشرفاء تحديدا الان التوجه باتجاه اتخاذ
موقف امريكا
هل يجب عليها ان تتخذ موقفان اما انها لن
تتخذ موقفا ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث باعتبار
او حتى الحكومه الشرعيه
لا حكومه البيبه في نهايه الامر هي متورطه
في هذه الجريمه الجريمه جريمه جريمه خيانه
عظمى لاهداف ضيقه ليست لها علاقه لا
بالعداله ولا غير ذلك تسليم مواطن ليبي
وتجرد عن كل القيم الوطنيه والاخلاقيه
ومفاهيم الاخوه الان ل- لكسب هذا الموقف
واليوم استاذ الكريم هو يوم حزين جدا طيب
كل اللي بين الذين التقي معهم في الشارع
العام حزينين بشده على هذا الموقف الان
ومن ثم منظمات المجتمع المدني الان
بامكانها ان تتواصل مع محامين او هيئه
دفاع في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكسب
هذه القضيه مهمه يعني سهله جدا من خلال
يعني اتباع قطور القانونيه فمهما قامت
المخابرات الامريكيه او السلطه التنفيذيه
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بهذا العمل
بالتنسيق مع حكومه لكن يظل القبائل
الامريكي يعني يتبع سياده القانون
القانونيه
يعني بامكانها في نهايه الامر ان يعني ان
تؤدي الى اخراج همم يعني عبوه عجيل المريم
نعم شكرا جزيلا دكتور فرج زيدان الباحث
السياسي اللي بكون تبعنا من بنغازي
[موسيقى]
كشفت وزيرته الدفاع الفرنسيه سابقه من
خلال اليومريه في برنامج الذاكره السياسيه
الذي سيتم بث حلقاته في وقت لاحقه على
شاشه العربيه ان شخصيا اتمنى النظام
السوري متورطه في جريمه اغتيال رئيس
الحكومه اللبنانيه الاسبق رفيق الحريري
وان المحكمه الدوليه الخاصه بلبنان تعرضت
للضغوط كبيره لتبديل قرارها النهائي وحسر
الجرائم بعناصر من من اشياء حزب الله
للتنويه مشاهدينا ستبث هذه المقابله في
وقت لاحق عبر برنامج ذاكره سياسيه مع زميل
طاهر
التونسيه
فقط
ولكن لماذا
حقيقي
وسيله
من اراد ان يحميه النظام السوري القيادات
على الاقل التي تورطت
النظام السوري
لكي تشطب اسماء بعض قياداتها المتورطه
كلمه مصري فيديو
اهلا بك الى هذه الدرجه النظام السوري
كانا قويا
بالضغوطات التي مورست على البحر
يعني تغيير اسماء او استبعاد اسماء من
مسؤولين النظام السوري
اولا يعني استغرب ان تقوم يعني سياسيه
فرنسيه
ووزير الدفاع سابقه
وهي من حزب شيراك على ما اعتقد استغرب ان
تقوم بهذه يعني بتصريحات تشبه هذا التصريح
الذي استمعت اليه بانتباه شديد
المساله لا تتعلق اليوم بان نضيفه اتهاما
الى النظام السوري رغم انني اعتقد بانه
المحكمه لم تبرء النظام السوري المحكمه
مجبره على ان تقدم يعني حكما على من تثبت
الى ادانته يعني اذا لم ت همم تمتلك
المحكمه
ادله وبينات حقيقيه لاتهام شخص فانا تمتنع
عن الاتهام وبالتالي اذا امتنعت عن
الانتهاء النظام السوري فنحنا نعتقد ان
هذا ليس يعني ان النظام السوري ولكنها
همم النظام المحكمه لا تمتلك لكي يعني
تدير النظام السوري لكن
اول دكتور حارق الاسميه نعم نعم نعم نعم
نعم نعم نعم نعم
اعطيني صبرك شويه ما تقوله
الوزيره الفرنسيه
نستطيع ان نفهمه ان كان لدى المحكمه
لتورط شخصيه سوريه كبيره ونتيجه ضغوط تم
اخفاء هذه الادله هذا يعني لا يطال فقط
عمل همم عمل همم المحكمه ونذهب الى ادانه
النظام السوري هذا الاعمال المحكمه بمجمله
يعني المحكمه التي التي تمتلك ادله
وتخفيها والتي تتعرض لظهور التي تاتيها
تعليمات فتنفذها بان تحصر همم يعني عملها
وادانتها باتجاه حزب الله هذا يضع كل عمل
المحكمه في في مهب الريح وبالتالي اعتقد
انه هذا الامر خطير جدا
وهذا الامر يعني همم لا يستطيع ان يسيء
لنظام السوري هو هذا الامر يسيء الى
المحكمه وايضا قد يعطي تصب الماء في
طاحونه حز اه الذي استهتر بالمحكمه
واعتبرها مسيسه طيب هل من الممكن ايضا فتح
هذا الملف مره اخرى اذا ما تقدمت الحكومه
اللبنانيه او او حتى مثلا همم رئيس
الحكومه الاسبق سعد الحريري باتهام جديد
هل هذا ممكن
استنادا الى هذا الى هذا القول
لا اعتقد ان الظروف يعني المحكمه همم يعني
ما زالت يعني اللبنانيين احنا تعاملوا مع
المحكمه
ودفعوا اسنان غالي همم من شهداءهم من اجل
اقراها ودفعه اسمها الغاليه من اجل
تمويلها همم كانوا يعولون على هذه المحكمه
بان تكون اكثر وضوحا واكثر
كفاءه واكثر فعاليه واليوم حين ياتي يعني
تاتي مسؤوله فرنسيه على هذا المستوى
وتشكك في عمل المحكمه سواء ايجابا ام
سالبا التشكيك بالمحكمه يعني يضعفها حتى
لو كانت تريد وزيره الدفاع الفرنسيه ان
تقول بانه همم يعني الاتهام لحزب الله ليس
كافيه ان يجب ان يكون هناك النظام السوري
الكل يعرف الظروف السياسيه التي اغتيل
فيها الرئيس الشهيد الحريري كانت ظروف
خلاف سياسي تمحور حول ال 1559 حول التمديد
لرئيس امين لحود وحول الانتخابات النيابيه
وبالتالي اذا كان يعني حزب الله الاتهام
حزب الله واذانته باغتيال
الحريري نتيجه الخلاف سياسي فان النظام
السوري كان جزء من هذا الخلاف السياسي
يعني الاتهام هنا الذي تضيفه السيده همم
الفرنسيه لا يضيف الى المشهد السياسي شيئا
بل العكس يسيء الى المحكمه ويشكر في
مصداقته شكرا جزيلا للكاتب السياسيه
الدكتور حار سليمان من بيروت شكرا جزيلا
لك
[موسيقى]
شروطهن جديده وضعتها واشنطن امام اوكرانيا
وتحديد المقابله مديها بالسلاح حيث قالتها
مصادر امريكيه لصحيفه وليتكو ان البنت
تكون ابلغوكانيا بضروره مشاركه اهداف
ضرباتها بالاسلحه الغربيه قبل التنفيذها
مشيره الى ان هذا الشرق جزء من التعهدات
الاوكرانيه العسكريه لضمان استمراريه
توريد الاسلحه الغربيه
خط الدفاع الروسيه يتراجع تدريجيا في
الجنوب الاوكراني بعد خساره خرسون يبدو
بان القوات الاوكرانيه عازمه على مواصله
استعاده مناطق اخرى وتضع القوات الاخرانيه
صوب عيونها الان وتوجه هذه الاعين الى
مدينه ميني توبل الواقعه في الجنوب
الاوكراني والتي تسيطر عليها القوات
الروسيه منذ بدايه العمليه العسكريه شهر
فبراير الماضي صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه
توقعت ان السعاده اوكرانيا لمدينه يعني
انهيار خط الدفاع الروسي باكمله على طول
الطريق الى الخير سون وهو ما يعطي القوه
الاخرانيه طريقا مباشره الى شبه جزيره
القرن كما تقول الصحيح
عموما يعني انسحاب بالخير شلون فضلا عن
خساره العديد من المدن في الشرق الاوكراني
وضع الرئيس الروسي بلادي مير بوتين في
موقف محرج مجله نيوز ويك الامريكيه نشرت
تقريرا لمعهد دراسه الحرب ومقره واشنطن
يكشف ان الرئيس الروسي ذات مهددا لفقدان
دعم الخلفائه الداخليه وهكذا تقريبا
وهو من قدام المحاربين في الجيش الروسي
ووزير الدفاع السابق لجمهوريه دونيسك التي
لعب دور الرئيسيه في ضم روسيا لشبه جزيره
القرن غير لهجته ضد بوتين واضاف واضافه
الى
اهلكوفيسكي وهو قائد روسي سابق من بين
اولئك الذين انتقدوا بوتين بشكل مباشر في
الايام الاخيره
معنى من موسكو المحلل السياسي
اهلا بك يعني انسحاب روسيا او عفوا انسحاب
الجيش الروسي من خيرسون بدايه كان يعطي
ايحاء بان القادم سيكون اشد على القوات
الاوكرانيه ولكن يبدو الان ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تجعل التقدم في تراجع الروسي
ما السبب
انا لا اعتقد بان يعني مثل هذه
انا يعني اوكرانيا ربما تحرز ااا بعض
النجاحات في الفتره الاخيره وبعد الانسحاب
الانسحاب القوات روسيه من غير صور هذه
لمبات اتفق والواقع لان المصادر العسكريه
الروسيه ومعها بعض المصادر الحياديه تقول
ان هناك همم ربما الوضع اصبح يراوح في
مكان تعبير وليس هناك الا ربما تقدماته
انسحابات طفيفه من الطرفين
في هذه المنطقه في منطقه اخرى لكنها
يجمعنا لا تؤثر على سير على العمليه
العسكريه التي تاخذها القوه الروسيه وانما
الان من المبكر جدا الحديث عن اي مثلا
تحول لصالح اي طرف من طرف الصراحه طيب هل
ايضا هذا يشمل ايضا التذمر الذي يكون عاده
بين القاده اوه سعر كنا نتحدث عن
جورجيا اضافه الى اجزندر خذو كوفيسكي
بالتالي ايضا الرئيس الشيشاني سابق كان
ايضا هو تذمر ايضا من اداء الجيش الروسي
في اوكرانيا
انا اعتقد بان كل هذه الامور كانت تحت
السيطره الكرمله يعني كان من الممكن ان
يكون هناك نقاش وحتى يحتضم يعني هذا الجدل
حول ربما تكتيك الذي اخترته القوه القياده
العسكريه الروسيه قبل بدعه اشهر بعد
الانتقادات التي وجهها الرئيس الشيشاني
قديره همم ببعض الوقت تم استبدال قياده
القوات همم الروسيه في اوكرانيا والان لا
احد يمكن ان ينتقد همم يعني عمل القاعده
الجديده السيد سيرجي
وهو بتبيعه الحال يتمتع الان باحترام الكل
بالاستا سواء اولئك الذين يؤيدون هذه
العمليه بشكل كامل ام اليك الذين كانوا
ينتقدونها ولكنها الان غيروا ارائهم
واصبحوا يؤيدون كل ما تقوم به القياده
العسكريه الجديده
شكرا جزيلا للمحل السياسي يبني يا سيد
رؤوفه من موسكو
[موسيقى]
اعلنت حكومه طالبان اليوم عن مقتل ثلاثه
مسلحين هجموا فندق في العاصمه كابولي
يرتده عاده الرجال اعمال صينيون يقع
الفندق الذي شهد الهجوم قرب القصر الرئاسي
واما قارات البعثات الدبلوماسيه وقد حصلت
العربيه على صور المتداوله لفراري للنزلاء
الفندق الذي تعرض لهجوم في العاصمه
الافغانيه كابول
[موسيقى]
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
مهاجره المتوسط عالقون بين ضفتي الحلم
والموت يوم نريد
بالتواضع في اعاده هم قصرا الى ليبيا
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله
بدلا من علامه واحده طرحتها منصه تمبلر
اعلان جديد منافسا وساخرا من تويتر
بثمن ايضا
7.99 دولارا لمره واحده
فقط
[موسيقى]
لم يكن حلم الوصول الى اوروبا سهل لكنه
بتشبه مستحيل الان بعد سياسات دول الاتحاد
المتشدده تجاه المهاجرين غير الشرعيه
بين ضفتيه وسط البحر لا ارضى الحن وصلوها
او تستقبلهم ولاقى قوارب الموت تنجيهم وفي
اخر الفصول هذه الازمه المتقلبه على امواج
المتوسط اتهمت منظمه الراس وكاله الحدود
التابعه للاتحاد الاوروبي
بانها سهله عودتهم عبر البحر الى ليبيا
كسرا بدلا من ان تنقذهم من منظمات غير
حكوميه او سفن عابره كانت ستقول لهم الى
اوروبا المنظمه قالت ان فرنسا
في
الانتهاكات عفوا ضد المهاجرين لانها فعلا
جيدا لان المهاجرين يواجهون معامله وحشيه
في ليبيا وذلك
اعدتهم الى ليبيا برونتكس من جانبها ردت
على تلك الاتهامات واكدت انها غير صحيحه
واعلنت ان طواقمها انقذت اكثر من 300,000
مهاجر في البحر في السنوات الاخيره
[موسيقى]
وعلى ضفه اخرى تشهد ازمه لجوء يعيش
مهاجرون مختبئون في غابات شمال فرنساويه
في انتظار فرصه للوصول الى بريطانيا
الشرطه تحاول منعهم من خلال مصادره
تحاجياتهم ومنع المنظمات من تقديم
المساعده له
هربا من ازمات وحروب في بلدانهم الاصليه
يتجمع على طرفي سكه القطار المهجوره هذه
شماليه فرنسا مهاجرون من جنسيات افغانيه
وسودانيه وحتى سوريه املا بتحقيق حلم
العبور من فرنسا الى بريطانيا لكن عبر
قوارب متهالكه في البحر هنا اقام
المهاجرون في غابات مدينه كالي عالما
موازيا ينغلق على نفسه وينقسم الى مجموعات
السوداني مع السوداني والافغاني مع
الافغاني اما لحظه التقاء الجميع فهي فقط
حين تاتي المساعدات وسائل الاعلام غير
المرحب بها هنا لان قنوات فرنسيه دابت على
شيطنت هؤلاء والتحريض عليهم فسرعان
ماتعاله الاصوات معترضه على وجودنا
اتفضل
الجمعيات ان الشرطه الفرنسيه مسؤوله عن
هذا الوضع فقبل يوم من وصولنا جرفت مركبات
الشرطه خياما وطعاما واغطيه ثم غادرت
تريكه مئات المهاجرين في برد قارس لقتل
حلمهم في العبور الى بريطانيا
بارد
جدا
التي احضرناها وضعوا حواجز لكي يمنع
المنظمات من المرور وتقديم المساعده
للمهاجرين البعض هنا اقترب بريطانيا لان
طلب لجوءه رفض في فرنسا وبعض اخر يسعى للم
شملن مع عائله له هناك جاؤوا مهاجر كردي
ايراني قابل بالتحدث الينا بعد رفض عشرات
من زملائه فقدنا بعيدا عن تجمعات
المهاجرين والمهربين الذين يندسون بينهم
منتحلي ناصفه مهاجر حتى لا نثير غضبهم
بريطانيا
لهذا السبب الكل يريد الذهاب الى بريطانيا
الوضع هنا سيء جدا الطقس بارد والشرطه
عدوانيه انها تاتي باستمرار لتصادر خيامنا
واكياس النوم نحن لسنا بخير هنا قبل عام
تماما غرق قريب يقول له 27 مهاجرا ابحر من
شواطئ كاليه بعض المهاجرين هنا لم يسمعوا
بالقصه لان الغ متى هي محطه عبور لا اكثر
تتجدد فيها الوجوه لكن الحلم واحد بالنسبه
للجميع وهو الوصول الى شواطئ بريطانيا
التي يمكن رؤيتها بالعين المجرده
فدهوك العربيه كاليه
تسبب سقوط الكثيف للثلوج في اجزاء من
بريطانيا ببعض الاضطرابات في مطارات
وخدمات القطار وشوارع لندن رحلات الجويه
تعطلت حركه القطارات شهد التاخيرات
والغاءات بسبب العاصفه الثلجيه
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
ايران
بمواصله تنفيذ الاعدامات والاخيره تفرض
على النظام عقوبات تطالب مسؤولين وكيانا
قضيه الكربيه واشنطن تتكتم على حيثيه
تسليم ابو عجينه
والبرلمان الليبيه يعتبرها جريمه
وزير الدفاع الفرنسيه السابقه تكشف
للعربيه تعرض المحكمه الخاصه باغتيال
الحريري لضغوط كبيره لتبديل قرارها
النهائي
[موسيقى]
روتين في مازق خسائر جيشه في اوكرانيا
تفقده دعم الحلفاء و واشنطن تضعوا شروط
جديده لمد كيف بالسلاح
اخبار الساعه انتهت ولكن الاخبار على
العربيه مستمره القاكم على راس الساعه بعد
قليل
[موسيقى]